Are you a bit worried about
the next few months or years, so
maybe a lot of consumption has been
brought forward in your place now, so all the
hardware store purchases of the last few years say that
they have already taken place and
will therefore be a little less in the future and then just like that  the recession
that is somehow hovering over us,
so it was years ahead of you, well, at
least I alone,
I don't even know how far I'm
thinking ahead, but the year 2023 alone
is not the best year in
which everything is put together  comes as you just
said also otherwise from the Corona PI
comes I think everyone has
bought their second grill and has
already fallen in love with one or the other holiday at home
and now maybe feels like
going on holiday somewhere else again, if at all the wallet
because now, as you
say, there is also inflation and the
reluctance to buy and of course we feel
that too, so I think there are now the
months that are ahead of us
and that is all the more important  but it is also important that
we continue with our change process in such a phase
and do not pause because it
also shows how markets are
changing again, how demand behavior is
changing and then we have to
be there with our
customers accordingly  a lot of customers is
independent of the app you have such a
normal month so that's fun
you have four million you might have about the app a
year but yes it's
difficult for you to
answer like that because we uh because we uh as I
said none  No customers
can measure one to one, so the
customer buys anonymously when
shopping at an OBI store, but we have
over 10 million customers who buy from us
a year or something between
10 and 15 million and
we have over 100 million
Tickets that were sold or on the
website in Germany we have over
250 million visits so there is already
a lot of this one there is also quite good
what has happened in society
so do you notice certain
changes there where say that is
actually still possible  little communicated,
for example, a few weeks ago
I was at an event, the
head of Rewe said that he
already senses very strongly that people now
go to discounts much more than they do,
so we see that too, we see
when you use Idealo price search engines if
because more traffic comes here or other
things like that we see we see when
people start
buying instead of buying brands we
see when customers start when
crises like this arise then they go ahead
and consult with each other before electricity generators
were bought a lot  because he
says who knows if there will be a major
power outage and so on and so on and
you can see the centiment
quite well in there but we
also regularly ask our customers about
our centiment because
that's what you are as a dealer then had to do
it  it's your turn to understand
what's keeping customers busy over the next few months
and
two or three years ago it was about
making the home nice and now
it's about making it more efficient
or maybe not even calling a craftsman
but repairing things yourself
because  the craftsman
is expensive, relatively expensive or
is fully booked and then you tend to do
the repairs and
maintenance yourself again, we see something like that
relatively quickly, the rate of
preppers in Germany has risen sharply there was an
amazing turnover to
change
so the whole topic  Gas then so
gas bottles then also the topic of
power generators yes or now
what if in Hamburg for example where
we are here
the whole topic of mold is also quite extreme right now because now there is
n’t that much ventilation anymore to
let the temperature out in you
suddenly have  much more mold growth and
uh you see that then yes and then
if there is mold then you have to
paint the wall again afterwards and so on
and so forth crass that is
amazing that you can do that immediately then
this yes I would wish we
could  even better actually
use it communicatively again to lead the customers
even better then when we
recognize such things we have to
get a little bit better because you
actually see the things you understand
them and then to translate them for the customer
also for those who do it  not not
become active yourself, but who you
can then somehow address with it, I think we can
actually do that better